So, what is the big picture with
virtualization? In either of the two approaches that
I mentioned, whether it is full virtualization or
parel virtualization, we have to virtualize, the hardware
resources and make them available safely to
the operating systems that are running on top
of the hypervisor. And when we talk about
hardware resources, we're talking about the memory hierarchy,
the CPU, and the devices that are there
in the hardware platform. How to virtualize them
and make them available in a transparent manner
for use by the operating systems that live above
the hypervisor? And how do we affect? Data
and control transfer between the guest operating systems
and the hyper-visor. So these are all the
questions that we will be digging deeper into in
this course module. That wraps up the basic introduction to
virtualization technology And now it is time to roll up
our sleeves and look deeper into the nuts and bolts
of virtualizing the different hardware elements in the hypervisor. .